I've seen a few posts on Reddit asking
if I'm natural so let's clear that up I
am
99.9% natural I don't use steroids trt
growth hormone or anything else I say
99.9% though because when I was around
23 I took a pro hormone now I know it
sounds a bit sus but I genuinely didn't
understand what it was they were legal
in the UK and this was being sold at my
gym like on the Shelf I thought it was
just like a testosterone booster I don't
consider that it contributed to my
physique in any sign way though I did
get bigger at the time but this wasn't
my biggest physique that was a few years
earlier when I worked as a writer in
leads for a year on work placement the
effect really wasn't that profound for
me so I certainly would characterize my
current physique as natural and it's
definitely attainable
naturally